This video is sponsored
by CuriosityStream. Use the link in the description
to start watching thousands of documentaries
and get access to our new educational streaming
service, Nebula, at no extra cost. One week
every year - either in January or February
- Chinese train stations, bus terminals, roads,
and airports overflow with travelers. Chinese
New Year is the largest human migration on
earth, with nearly 400 million people returning
home to their families. For comparison, Thanksgiving
sees 50 million travelers, the Arba'een Pilgrimage,
40 million, and India’s Kumbh Mela, 30.
Rather than give workers a yearly allowance
of paid leave, Chinese factories and companies
shut down completely for two weeks of the
year: around the Lunar New Year and National
Day. These ‘Golden Weeks’ test the limits
of China’s world-class transportation network.
Many of the country’s notoriously-high toll
fees which are normally designed to disincentivize
driving, are suspended, creating 40-kilometer
or 25-mile traffic jams. Train and plane tickets
sell out in minutes, prices skyrocket, and,
then, the celebrations begin. Kids receive
lucky red envelopes filled with cash, incense
is burned for ancestors, and fireworks light
up the sky. In 2019, the year of the pig was
celebrated with giant statues in malls, parade
floats, billboards, and, in Hong Kong, pig
nose-shaped fireworks. The only things missing
were actual… pigs. In the last two years,
a third China’s pigs have died in the largest
ever animal disease outbreak, causing pork
prices to more than double. Now, losing such
a large source of food would be disastrous
anywhere, but for the largest pork-consuming
country on the planet, under an administration
whose power hinges on its ability to raise
the standard of living, during a trade war
with the country who supplies its pig feed,
is a crisis some consider more dangerous for
Beijing than the Taiwanese presidential elections,
the ban on Huawei, or, even the Hong Kong protests.
Pigs are the ideal farm animals.
They don’t require much space, they bear
about 12 piglets twice a year, and they eat
just about anything. Because of this, they’ve
long been an important part of the Chinese
diet. But not for the reason you might expect.
Mao Zedong called pigs “fertilizer factories
on four legs”, ordering they be fed leftover
household scraps to produce high-nutrient
manure which would, in turn, produce higher
grain yields. So, while nearly every family
ownedpigs, eating pork was a rare luxury,
reserved for holidays like the New Year. Today,
pork is still seen as a luxury, but one that
everyone now expects. About half of the world’s
pork is consumed in China, and that’s not
just because of its large population. Adjusted
per capita, China, Hong Kong, and Macau eat
the 4th most pork in the world. Even more
impressive, that’s despite China’s $16,807
Per Capita GDP, compared to 3rd place, the
European Union’s $41,091. Pork accounts
for two-thirds of all meat consumed in China,
with poultry accounting for 21%, beef, 8%,
and lamb, 5. But even these numbers don’t
adequately explain the Chinese obsession with
pigs. Throughout the country, pork is an almost
default ingredient. Dim Sum, dumplings, rice,
noodles, soup, even, sometimes, desert, contains
pork, whether it’s listed on the menu or
not. The Chinese word for meat, “ròu”
literally means pork. All other types of meat
have to be specified. Cows, for example, are
“niú”, so beef is “niú ròu”. Fish,
“Yú”, becomes “Yú ròu”. And so
on. The Chinese character for family or home,
“Jiā” is composed of two elements, or
radicals - the character for roof underneath
the character for pig. All of this is to say:
pork is more than just a meal in China - it’s
ingrained in the culture. Which is why its
outbreak of African Swine Fever is so troubling.
The good news is that the virus isn’t dangerous
to humans. The bad news is that it’s basically
pig Ebola. The difference is that Ebola isn’t
airborne, only remains active for a few days
at room temperature, and only has about a
50% fatality rate. African Swine Fever, meanwhile,
spreads like wildfire. It’s found in all
the body fluids and tissues of its victims,
who experience vomiting, high temperatures,
and difficulty breathing. Some variants have
a 100% mortality rate. But death doesn’t
stop the virus from spreading. It lives in
feces and urine for days and can be spread
through flies, ticks, insects, vehicles, equipment
or clothing. And because there’s no vaccination,
the only solution is to kill and bury all
infected animals. As of 2019, the virus has
reached Vietnam, Cambodia, Mongolia, North
Korea, Hong Kong, and every province of China.
Official Chinese government sources estimate
$140 billion in direct losses and the death
of a quarter of the world’s pigs. Although
these numbers are likely inaccurate. Because
government subsidies for affected farms are
set below-market prices, both local government
officials and farmers themselves are incentivized
to hide and under-report the scale of the
outbreak. Regardless, the central government
simply doesn’t have many options. Many countries
keep emergency supplies of their national
obsessions: Canada has the Strategic Maple
Syrup Reserve, The U.S. has the Petroleum
Reserve, and China, since 2008, has the Strategic
Pork Reserve, comprised of live farms and
dozens of highly-guarded storehouses where
packaged pork is frozen and rotated. When
prices rise, supplies fall, or in the days
before the New Year, the government releases
some of its supply onto the market. The exact
amount of pork kept is a national secret but
is said to be around 200,000 tons, which,
compared to the country’s demand for 50
million tons every year, hardly makes a difference
during a crisis of this magnitude. The government
has lifted import bans, tried breeding giant
pigs, and some restaurants have resorted to
cooking with dog or rabbit meat. High pork
prices present Beijing with not just an economic
but also a political problem. For older generations,
being able to eat a once annual treat every
day is a symbol and reminder of their country’s
progress. When pork is unavailable or too
costly, on the other hand, it awakens grim
memories of China’s dark and hungry past.
While international attention focuses on stories
like Hong Kong’s protests, it’s easy to
forget that fighting for democracy is a privilege
afforded to the already moderately well-off.
For millions of Chinese, the number one concern
is putting food on the table, and losing their
favorite source of protein is more than merely
inconvenient. Even with reports of slowing
inflation, it will undoubtedly take years
for China’s pig population to fully recover.
In the future, China is expected to shift
more of its pig farming to large, industrial
factories, giving it more direct control over
their operations. There’s one silver lining,
however: the outbreak provides a golden opportunity
for China to embrace artificial and more sustainably
grown meat. Less than 2% of China’s population
is currently vegetarian, and eating meat is
very much part of Chinese life. So too, however,
is tea, and yet, companies like Starbucks
and Luckin’ Coffee have seen explosive growth
in China. In one survey of 30 countries, 73%
of Chinese respondents said they would eat
a plant-based meat substitute - higher than
any other country, including India. And China’s
Ministry of Health released guidelines in
2016 recommending people cut their meat consumption
in half by 2020. No one expects China to suddenly
become the leader in artificially grown meat,
but, twenty years ago, neither did anyone
expect it to become the electric vehicle capital
of the world, or lay more high-speed rail
than the rest of the world combined, or use
almost exclusively mobile payments, and yet
here we are. China’s authoritarian model
has led to miraculously rapid technological
progress. The pig could be next. There’s
another story about China I’m excited to
tell but not quite ready to release. I’ve
been working on and traveling for an exclusive,
extra-long video coming soon to Nebula, an
educational streaming service by some of your
favorite YouTubers, including Kurzgesagt,
CGP Grey, Kento Bento, Wendover Productions,
Half as Interesting, Tech Altar and Real Life
Lore. We’ve worked out a special deal with
Curiosity Steam, so when you sign up with
my link in the description, you not only get
their catalog of thousands of documentaries
- including this series on China - but also
access to Nebula so you can watch many of
our videos ad-free along with exclusives.
The annual subscription was an already affordable
$20 a year but now, with Nebula, it’s an
exceptionally good deal. And, if you’re
quick, it’s just $12 for the holidays. When
you sign up with my link, you’ll get a welcome
email with access to Nebula. Thanks to Curiosity
Stream and to you for watching this video.